herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live in
vier russisch besetzten Gebieten in der
Ukraine geht heute der letzte Tag der
sogenannten Referenten der
pseudo-referenten zu Ende denn das
Ergebnis dürfte im Grunde genommen in
Moskau schon feststehen der Anschluss an
Russland die Annexion schließlich
spricht man in Moskau seit Tagen schon
davon dass nun ja Russland im Don Bass
verteidigt werde man wartet also das
Ergebnis dieser pseudo-referenten
überhaupt gar nicht ab wir wollen hören
wir werden hören was der ukrainische
Gouverneur der ukrainischen Region
luhans zu berichten hat Herr i Hadi wir
sprechen mit unserem Korrespondentin
Moskau Christian SEM und wir sprechen
mit der
Sicherheitsexpertin Ulrike Franke vom
European Council ofarand relations die
natürlich gerne auch alle Fragen die
über Facebook Youtube kommen beantwortet
zunächst aber Nina Niebergall über den
Tag in der Ukraine
im russischen Staatsfernsehen zeigen sie
heute lange Schlangen vor den
Wahllokalen die Botschaft seht her sie
alle wollen zu Russland gehören
für alles Gute stimmen wir ab wir hoffen
darauf dass es geschehen wird dass alles
Gute was es in Russland gibt zu uns
kommen wird
doch vor die Kamera geht hier in der
selbsternannten Volksrepublik Don jetzt
nur werben russischen Sinne spricht
jenseits der russischen
Berichterstattung sahen die Abstimmungen
oft so aus im lange umkämpften Marie
yupol etwa gehen Wahlhelfer von Tür zu
Tür begleitet von Soldaten es wählt wer
nicht geflohen ist manche zumindest
unter vorsichtigen Protest das ist
illegal wir wollen nicht dass jeder
sieht was wir tun
ob sie den Anschluss an Russland wollen
diese Frau macht ihr Kreuzbein nein das
ist einen Unterschied macht daran glaubt
sie nicht
wir entscheiden nicht die über uns
entscheiden
unter solchen Bedingungen seien die
Referenten eine Farce zu der Vorwurf von
ukrainischer Seite
es gibt eine kleine Anzahl von Leuten
die so etwas wie ein zustimmungszeichen
auf den Stimmzettel setzen muss warum
weil ein Mann mit einem Gewehr zu ihrem
Haus kommt und sie auffordert
abzustimmen was sollen die Leute da tun
fast über alles der Urnengang inzwischen
beendet schon jetzt verkünden Russland
Treue Wahlleiter erste Ergebnisse es
zeichne sich ein überwältigendes ja ab
reden wir mit unserem Haus von Enten
Christian sem in Moskau Christian
erstmal schönen guten Abend Christian
wie wird denn in Russland über diese
pseudo-referenten Berichte sieht man zum
Beispiel da auch Videos die zeigen dass
doch unter Zwang abgestimmt wird ein
Soldat mit Waffe im Hintergrund steht
nein solche Bilder sieht man hier nicht
im Staatsfernsehen wird natürlich auch
darüber berichtet und auch schon
vorausschauend was dann nach diesen
Abstimmungen passieren soll und im
Prinzip wurde das ja auch schon lange
vorbereitet durch die durch die
Propaganda die die Menschen hier vor
allem im Fernsehen sehen können dass
dieser Schritt nötig waren diese
altbewährten narrative werden da
wiederholt das diese Gebete eben befreit
werden mussten von den Neonazis die da
die Bevölkerung unterdrücken also im
Fernsehen erfährt man hier alles läuft
nach Plan und alles so wie das gewünscht
ist
du sagst gerade das alte narrativ wird
da wiederholt was ist denn das
grundsätzliche Ziel warum diese
Referenten in Windeseile
naja man hat jetzt also offiziell wird
natürlich gesagt wie schon eben gesagt
habe dass es jetzt eben nötig ist dass
man diese Gebiete befreien muss weil
eben dort Neonazis herrschen mit
Unterstützung des Westens und der der
geballten NATO und da sieht sich so hat
es Vladimir Putin auch formuliert in
seiner ankündigen er sieht sich Russland
jetzt gezwungen da zurück zu da
einzustreiten und eben die Bevölkerung
zu unterstützen und diese Gebiete
zurückzuholen und wieder an Russland
anzugliedern
wir haben es eben in dem Beitrag ja auch
schon so ein bisschen gesehen da im
russischen Staatsfernsehen da werden
Zahlen schon gezeigt wird denn über
irgendeinen Ausgang schon berichtet
läuft da die Propaganda schon mit
gewissen zahlen
ja also die Wahlen ging ja bis zum
Nachmittag und relativ schnell wurden
dann schon erste Zahlen veröffentlicht
also Zwischenstände nach
unterschiedlichen auszählungsständen
also er wurde schon nach 12% der
Auszählung 27 % der Auszählung 57% der
Auszählung über diese Zwischenstände
berichtet die wurde wurden hier über die
Nachrichtenagenturen oder das
veröffentlicht die Zustimmung ist sehr
hoch nach diesen Zahlen also liegen dann
zwischen 87% oder sogar noch höher bei
97 oder 98 Prozent aber wir haben es
eben im Beitrag auch noch mal gesehen
die Bedingungen unter denen da
abgestimmt wird und dieses Ergebnis wird
würde ja auch nie anerkannt werden vom
Westen insofern sind die Zahlen sage ich
mal nicht so wichtig die sind später
vielleicht wichtig wenn hier in Russland
das Ergebnis verkündet wird und man der
eigenen Bevölkerung doch zeigen will mit
welcher hohen Zustimmung die Menschen
dort abgestimmt haben für einen Beitritt
zur Russischen Föderation
aber Wahlbeobachter gibt es keine oder
doch es gibt Wahlbeobachter es gibt auch
wahlberater aus Deutschland da gab es ja
einen
bekannten Fall aber ich glaube wir
können mit Fug und Recht sagen dass das
natürlich nicht Wahlbeobachter sind
die jetzt nach den sonstigen westlichen
Maßstäben und demokratischen Maßstäben
arbeiten
jetzt hast du gerade deutlich gemacht es
geht alles in Windeseile schnell schnell
das Ziel ist eigentlich auch bekannt wie
dürfte es denn jetzt weitergehen
wahrscheinlich ja auch in hohem Tempo in
wenigen Tagen dann schon die Annexion
also wir werden jetzt nach und nach
Ergebnisse erfahren je nachdem wie
schnell dann zumindest wieder dann auch
behauptet wird wie schnell ausgezählt
wird dann wird es da zum Schluss eine
Zahl stehen und ein Ergebnis verkündet
werden und dann wird das morgen oder
übermorgen vielleicht schon werden dann
Endergebnisse verkündet und dann kann es
ganz schnell gehen dann geht das hier
sozusagen in einem in dem Prozess der
Gesetzgebung dann werden Gesetze
unterzeichnet das geht dann hier durch
die Duma also diesen Schein will man
nach außen hin ja auch waren und dann
wird erwartet dass Vladimir Putin sich
in einer Rede äußert entweder an die
Duma an die Abgeordneten oder auch ans
Volk oder auch beides es gibt Gerüchte
und Mutmaßung dass das schon am Freitag
sein könnte andere Stimmen sagen dass
passiert dann vielleicht erst nächste
Woche aber ja wir können schon sagen
dass das eher eine Frage von Tagen ist
wann genau wissen wir noch nicht an
genauer Zeitplan wurde da noch nicht
festgelegt aber es ist klar dass man
damit jetzt auch eilig hatten Vladimir
Putin da schnell Fakten schaffen will
skandai ist Gouverneur der ukrainischen
Region lu Hans die ist zum allergrößten
Teil von den Russen besetzt unter
russischer Kontrolle wir wollten
allerdings von ihm wissen was er heute
gehört hat aus seiner Heimat aus luhans
wie die Leute dort zum Wählen gebracht
worden sind und das hat er uns erzählt
das läuft ziemlich komisch ab für
Menschen die verstehen was eine legitime
Abstimmung bedeutet
die Menschen werden in Häusern und
Wohnungen von bewaffneten Männern in
Uniform aufgesucht sie werden gezwungen
zu wählen es gibt keine vorbereiteten
Wahllokale
manchmal stehen Tische mit Stimmzetteln
auf den Straßen die Menschen die
Vorbeigehen werden zur Wahl gerufen
selbst wenn die Menschen keine Papiere
dabei haben und Ihre Identität nicht
nachweisbar ist
Herr Christian also Kritik von ihm von
dem Gouverneur der ukrainischen Region
luhans wie ist das denn in Moskau wie
ist das in Russland gibt es denn da auch
irgendwie kritische Stimmen die sagen
also das Referendum das geht doch so
nicht
die Stimmen gibt es bestimmt nur die
hören wenn ich weil in den letzten
Monaten und Wochen und Jahren sind hier
die kritischen Stimmen die
kritische Presse die freie Presse die
ist hier systematisch ausgeschaltet
worden und wir haben ja vor einigen
Tagen immer wieder auch zarte Anflüge
von Protesten gesehen es gab ja
landesweitproteste in Moskau waren wir
auch selbst vor diesen Protesten und wer
jetzt dagegen ist gegen diesen Anschluss
auch gegen die Mobilmachung vielleicht
auch generell gegen den Krieg um die
gegen die Politik des Präsidenten der
hat hier im Prinzip keine Chance dass
irgendwo öffentlich zu äußern wer jetzt
auf die Straße geht und sich lauthals
hinstellt und ein Ende des Kriegs
fordert der läuft Gefahr sofort
festgenommen zu werden der kann seine
Kritik vielleicht auch noch nicht mal im
Interview mit den mit den Medien äußern
wir haben das selbst erlebt wir haben
auf den Demonstrationen gedreht haben
mit einem Demonstranten gesprochen und
der wurde uns vom Mikrofon wegverhaftet
später haben wir erfahren dass er dafür
15 Tage Haft bekommen hat also das
scheint jetzt auch eine neue order zu
sein mit der Presse spricht wird sofort
mitgenommen
also wirklich drastische Maßnahmen du
hast es aber jetzt selber gerade ja
angeschnitten das Thema eben
Mobilmachung die Teilmobilmachung in
Russland die Putin angekündigt hat und
die angefangen hat wie läuft sie denn
eigentlich was ist davon zu hören
das hören wir jetzt öffentlich immer
wieder auch von eigentlich
putinentrollen stimmen und Institutionen
das ist teilweise überhaupt nicht läuft
dass Männer eingezogen werden die dafür
eigentlich gar nicht vorgesehen sind die
entweder zu alt sind oder bestimmte
Berufe ausüben die nicht betroffen sein
sollten da sind Fehler passiert das hat
er Kreml auch öffentlich eingeräumt also
das läuft nicht andererseits wird
berichtet dass es eben gut läuft dass
ich viele Freiwillige melden und dass
die Unterstützung auch groß ist ich
glaube dieser Schritt der hat große
Panik ausgelöst in der russischen
Gesellschaft in jeder Familie fragt sich
jetzt jeder ist der Bruder betroffen ist
der ist der Vater betroffen ist der
Onkel betroffen weil die Kriterien eben
dann doch nicht so genau sind und viele
Angst haben dass sie doch
darunter fallen könnten und jetzt
eingezogen werden und wir haben das in
den letzten Tagen ja auch gesehen auf
verschiedenen Bildern von der finnischen
Grenze von der georgischen Grenze sogar
von der Grenze zur Mongolei das viele
Russen jetzt versuchen tausende zehn
ganz genau Zahlen gibt es nicht die
schwanken auch immer wieder aber wir
können davon ausgehen dass es sehr sehr
viele sind die versuchen jetzt dann doch
das Land zu verlassen und diesem Einzug
zum Militär zu entgehen weil sie eben
nicht diesen Krieg an der Front
unterstützen wollen und ich glaube es
hat sich grundlegend was geändert eben
durch diese Mobilisierung es gab
jahrelang hier sozusagen ja wie ein
ungeschriebenes Gesetz an
ungeschriebenen Vertrag zwischen dem
Präsidenten und dem und dem der zwischen
der Führung und dem Volk denn nämlich so
aussieht ihr mischt euch nicht in die
Politik ein und dafür lassen wir euch in
Ruhe und das hat sich jetzt natürlich
schlagartig geändert durch diese
Mobilisierung jetzt ist fast jede
Familie betroffen davon
also du sagst ja die Zahlen schwanken
aber sie sind halt hoch um einfach mal
welche zu nennen wir lesen hier der
georgische Innenminister meldet dass
bisher 5.6000 Russen pro Tag über die
Grenze gekommen sind nach Georgien jetzt
ist die Zahl oder sei die Zahl
mittlerweile auf 10.000 Russen männliche
also Russen pro Tag gewachsen die sich
also dieser teilmobil machen entziehen
wollen der kasachische Präsident sagt
ebenfalls wir müssen diesen Einreisenden
Schutz bieten wir nehmen sie auf es
werden eben da auch immer mehr und
insofern ist das ja ja man kann ja auch
sagen ein Protest mit den Füßen denn wer
nicht lauter auf die Straße gehen kann
und Angst hat der kann eben wenigstens
versuchen ins Ausland sich abzusetzen
das ist ja ein deutliches Zeichen nehmen
denn aber du hast das eben sehr schön
gesagt so ein Hauch von Protesten nehmen
denn diese Proteste zu wir haben jetzt
gestern vorgestern auch Bilder aus
Dagestan gesehen gerade in den ärmeren
Regionen wo ja doch sehr viel rekrutiert
worden ist nehmen da die Proteste zu
dass die Leute sagen wir haben es jetzt
langsam satt hier dieses Kanonenfutter
in Anführungsstrichen zu stellen
ja du hast es angesprochen vor allem in
den Teilrepubliken da waren die Proteste
am heftigsten und am lautstärkesten das
auch gefallen dass die Polizei dort
nicht mit massiver Montur und Mannstärke
reingegangen ist wie jetzt in den großen
Städten wie in St Petersburg wo es
besonders brutal war oder auch in Moskau
da zum Beispiel in Dagestan haben sich
auch ganz viele Frauen auf die Straße
gegangen die ist dann schützen vor ihrer
Männer und zwischen die Polizei geworfen
haben und eben lautstark signalisiert
haben dass sie damit eben nicht
einverstanden sind also das ist
lautstark ob die Proteste jetzt mehr
werden oder größer werden ist im Moment
schwer zu sagen ich habe nicht den
Eindruck das sind immer wieder Versuche
Proteste zu starten aber ich glaube was
in Russland fehlt um wirklich lautstarke
große Proteste zu organisieren mit
hunderttausenden die vielleicht auf die
Straße gehen das sind prominente Köpfe
das sind prominente Köpfe der Opposition
die eben auch eine gewisse Reichweite
haben und die das schaffen können so
viele Menschen zu mobilisieren der
letzte der das hier konnte war Alexa
valny und der ist eben im Straflager und
ist bei vielen hier schon ja fast in
Vergessenheit geraten und er kann das
aus dem Straflager kann er das nicht
machen obwohl er sich zu den Protesten
und zu der Mobilisierung jetzt auch
schon geäußert hat und das auch
verurteilt
Christian du hast es gerade eben schon
gesagt die zahlen weil er gesagt wird
nach 57 Prozent der ausgezählten Stimmen
etc du sagst ja selber deine
Einschätzung ist auf die Zahlen wird gar
nicht so viel jetzt gegeben es geht
hauptsächlich darum ein Jahr ich will
aber die Frage an dich weiterleiten die
wir über Youtube bekommen die
Wahlbeteiligung schreibt jemand würde
mich interessieren jetzt verfolgst du
also das was die Wahlkommission sagt was
der Staatsfernsehen sagt wird denn da
auch irgendetwas gesagt was so ein
Hinweis vielleicht auch geben könnte ob
wirklich alle zur Wahl da gehen oder ob
es doch eher eine zwangssache ist
es gibt Zahlen zur Wahlbeteiligung in
die waren auch schwanken die sind jetzt
auch endgültig noch nicht veröffentlicht
ich habe jetzt die aktuellen Zahlen
nämlich jetzt nicht da aber es gibt die
Zahlen die werden natürlich
veröffentlicht und zum Schluss ergibt
sich daraus natürlich einen Gesamtbild
aus Wahlbeteiligung
und dann eben diesem Ergebnis und
natürlich wird man hier versuchen diese
Zahlen auf jeden Fall für das eigene
narrativ zu verwenden und zu benutzen
und daraus eben abzuleiten dass es eine
große Zustimmung gibt dass die Menschen
die dort leben unbedingt Teil der der
Russischen Föderation werden wollten
denn Putin braucht auch diese große
Zustimmung denn er muss damit natürlich
auch werben können für diese
Mobilisierung um den Menschen hier klar
zu machen auf den Männern die jetzt
vielleicht an die Fronten müssen warum
es so wichtig ist jetzt für Russland da
zu sein also insofern werden auch diese
Zahlen mit Vorsicht zu genießen sein
Christian sem vielen vielen Dank für die
Eindrücke für die Informationen und
Schilderungen und du wirst weiterhin die
Sache natürlich beobachten und wir
werden weiterhin von dir auf Laufenden
gehalten Christian in Moskau vielen Dank
ja werden diese Schein Referenden auch
die aktuelle Gegenoffensive der Ukraine
die ja in den vergangenen Tagen in den
vergangenen Wochen erfolgreich war
beeinflussen auf diese Frage war die
Antwort des ukrainischen Außenministers
heute kurz und knapp nein er sagte
wörtlich diese Maßnahmen diese
Entscheidung von Russlands Präsidenten
Putin werden keinen Einfluss auf die
Politik Diplomatie und das Handeln der
Ukraine auf dem Schlachtfeld haben so
cool aber heute auf einer
Pressekonferenz welche militärischen
Fortschritte die ukrainischen Truppen
heute in den vergangenen Tagen gemacht
haben wie die Situation da ist das hat
sich Christian Volk angeschaut
die militärische Lage ohne Ton bringt
uns leider nicht so viel auch wenn wir
nicht erfahren was der ukrainische
Präsident Selens gemacht sagt macht aber
nichts denn wir können jetzt direkt
sprechen mit Ulrike Franke von dem
European Council of Foreign Affairs ganz
liebe Grüße nach London und vielen Dank
schon mal dass Sie sich die Zeit
genommen haben sehr gerne Frau Franke
kommen wir eben zur militärischen Lage
dann fragen wir Sie ganz einfach und Sie
können das beschreiben also in den
letzten Tagen haben wir gesehen in den
letzten Wochen eben ein sage ich mal
Momentum dass die Ukraine genutzt haben
Tag für Tag neue Berichte man hat so und
so viel an Quadratkilometern
zurückerobert Dörfer zurück erobert aber
wird dieses Momentum weiter benutzt
kommt das Ganze zum Stillstand oder wie
geht es weiter
es ist natürlich sehr schwer
vorherzusagen Momentum ist unglaublich
wichtig in militärischen Operationen und
insofern dass die Ukraine es geschafft
hat nach diesen vielen Monaten des
Krieges jetzt eben das Momentum wieder
zurück zu erobern ist beeindruckend und
wichtig und erklärt eben dann auch zum
Teil warum es diese wichtigen Gebiets
Gewinne gab das wird sich natürlich
nicht ewig so weiterführen lassen
schlichen ergreifend deswegen weil die
Gebiete die erobert werden müssen ja
auch gesichert werden der Ukraine fehlen
natürlich letztendlich auch noch mehr
Equipment auch die Ukraine hat natürlich
sehr viele Soldaten verloren diese diese
Operation der letzten Monate und gerade
die Erfolge der letzten Tagen und Wochen
dienten auch sehr dazu den besten zu
zeigen schaut mal was ihr mit den ganzen
Waffen die uns liefert was wir mit den
Waffen wie wir uns liefern auch
erreichen können das war insofern auch
ganz wichtig aber um jetzt da noch viele
Quadratkilometer mehr zu erobern das
immer so weiterzuführen ja wird die
Ukraine auch weiterhin mehr Waffen
brauchen insofern wir sollen jetzt nicht
denken dass das ist jetzt das Momentum
das geht jetzt immer so weiter und wenn
es durchaus sein kann dass da noch ein
bisschen was kommt aber letztendlich
werden die Ukrainer versuchen sich jetzt
eine gute Position zu bringen auch auch
vor dem Winter und bevor dann die
Truppen der der russischen Mobilisierung
auch auf dem dem Kriegsgebiete
letztendlich eintreffen da wollen wir
einfach mal hören was der ukrainische
Gouverneur der Region luhans dazu sagt
zu der militärischen Lage und auch zu
den Zielen der ukrainischen Armee
nach der blitzschnellen Operation hakiff
nehmen die ukrainischen Truppen das
Tempo nicht raus sie führen die
Gegenoffensive weiter sowohl in Richtung
hakif als auch in Richtung lohansk Don
jetzt Carson überall kommen die Truppen
nach vorne vielleicht nicht so schnell
wie ein haarkiff aber sie kommen jeden
Tag voran
ist die Frage an die Sicherheitsexpertin
ist das denn realistisch oder spricht da
ein bisschen mehr der Optimismus statt
der Realismus
dass man also in alle Richtungen so
weitergeht denn sie haben ja auch gerade
gesagt irgendwie hat es die Erfolge
gegeben und es war ein Zeichen seht her
was man mit den westlichen Waffen
schaffen kann bedarf ist nicht erstmal
mehr Waffen oder auch Nachschub dass die
Ukraine dieses Momentum fortsetzen kann
also diese Rückeroberung fortsetzen kann
mit solchen vorhersagen kann man diesen
Krieg ja eigentlich fast nur falsch
liegen es hat sich an diesem Krieg viel
getan was so nicht erwartet wurde
insofern will ich mir da gar kein Urteil
erlauben aber natürlich ist da auch eine
ukrainischen Seite in gewisses Maß an an
Propaganda und Messaging sowohl nach
innen für die eigenen Truppen als auch
nach außen dem unterstützenden Westen
drin es ist klar dass die Ukraine weiter
versucht zu pushen die will die UK Dinge
die wir die besetzten Gebiete der
Ukraine zurückerobern hat sie natürlich
auch jedes Recht zu aber ich würde schon
denken um das jetzt in diesem Tempo mit
diesen Erfolgen die wir in den letzten
Tagen und Wochen gesehen haben
weiterzuführen ja wird die Ukraine auch
mehr und und weiterhin Waffen brauchen
daher ist es einfach wichtig dass der
Westen sich jetzt nicht denkt das hat
sich jetzt gedreht und wir können das
jetzt laufen lassen so ist es sicherlich
nicht Ukraine wird da viel versuchen
aber Russland bleibt weiterhin ein
starker Gegner oder zumindest eben ja
ein großer Gegner und jetzt gerade mit
der Mobilisierung von diesen 300.000
werden nicht mehr Soldaten bitte auch
noch einiges auf die Ukraine zukommen
selbst wenn das jetzt kein gut
ausgebildeten Soldaten sind
das ist aber genau eine Frage ist das
jetzt wird das jetzt die Gewichte
verschieben wenn 300.000 russische ja
Männer rekrutiert werden und dann an die
Front geschickt werden kann das jetzt
sozusagen den Ausgang eben auch
verändern
es kann den Ausgang verändern natürlich
also diese Mobilisierung ist mit
Vorsicht zu genießen als dass es eben
von allem was wir hören nicht gut
ausgebildete Reservisten sind die da
jetzt an die Front geschickt werden
sondern teilweise Männer die gar keine
militärische Erfahrung haben also man
hat wirklich den Eindruck da wird ganz
krass gesagt kann nun Futter rekrutieren
aber diese Zahlen wenn Russland es
schafft jetzt schnell auf diese Soldaten
auf Schlachtfeld zu bringen hat das
natürlich trotzdem einen Einfluss
300.000 auch mehr ist natürlich schon
eine relevante Zahl während der Ukraine
mit jedem Tag mehr
jeden Tag mehr Soldaten verliert
insofern da kommt jetzt ein bisschen auf
die Geschwindigkeit auch an es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich dass Russland
wirklich versucht diese Truppen sehr
schnell auf Schlachtfeld zu bringen also
da geht es um Training von nur zwei
Wochen das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht
ausreichend das bedeutet auch dass dann
die Truppen letztendlich wie so Partisan
Kämpfer irgendwie auf dem Schlachtfeld
noch weiter trainiert werden aber sie
sind dann eben potenziell vor Ort und
das kann schon einen Einfluss haben
wahnsinnig viel Angst muss da jetzt
meines Erachtens ihnen nicht haben weil
das jetzt weiß Gott keine gut
ausgebildeten Spezialkräfte sind aber
ich Quantität hat im Krieg immer auf
seine eigene Qualität daher sollte man
das auch nicht unterschätzen nur weil es
hier um drucken geht die jetzt
vielleicht nicht besonders gut
ausgebildet oder auch besonders gut
ausgeschaltet
ganz kurz einfach mal diese
Teilmobilmachung läuft jetzt ganz
schnell die Referenten sind im ich sag
mal jetzt ein Windeseile durchgezogen
worden
was zeigt das Ganze im Westen wird auch
sehr oft hier gesagt dass sei ein Akt
der Verzweiflung ist es ein doppelter
Akt der Verzweiflung von Putin
ich würde sagen es ist eine Eskalation
aus der Position der Schwäche
das macht es nicht weniger gefährlich
das macht es sogar noch gefährlicher
aber es ist ja schon so dass die
Mobilisierung etwas ist was was Wladimir
Putin nicht wollte und was jetzt nötig
geworden ist
wie gesagt es ist trotzdem eine
Eskalation das bedeutet trotzdem dass
die Truppen dann auf den auf dem
Schlachtfeld sind das macht es
schwieriger für die Ukraine aber es
zeigt eben auch dass dieser dieser Krieg
in keinster Weise so läuft für Russland
wie sich Putin das vorgestellt hat
insofern würde ich das als jetzt
zweischneidiges Schwert bezeichnen die
scheinreferenten und es ist wirklich
ganz wichtig dass wir betonen das ist
eine Bass diese Referenzen sind
völkerrechtswidrig das ist komplett egal
was da rauskommt das hat überhaupt
keinen Einfluss da geht es natürlich vor
allen Dingen darum Propaganda nach innen
zu betreiben also zum zum russischen
Volk und eben so suggerieren diese
Menschen wollen zu Russland gehören und
auch in Richtung Westen die die das
Signal zu senden das sind jetzt
russische Gebiete von Russland eine
Kirche Gebiete und wenn da die Ukraine
angreift und zurückerobern will dann ist
das ein Angriff auf russische
Staatsgebiet das ist natürlich
kompletter Unsinn das müssen wir
weiterhin tun das ist kompletter Unsinn
aber das soll suggeriert werden das ist
die narrative und ja auch hier das macht
das Ganze wieder gefährlicher insofern
wir treten jeden Tag in einer
gefährlichere Situation in den Krieg in
den Krieg ein trotzdem können wir uns
natürlich über die ukrainischen Erfolge
freuen aber es bleibt dabei die ist noch
nichts gewonnen die ist noch nichts zu
Ende wir sind weit entfernt von einem
Waffenstillstand soweit ich das
einschätzen kann und ja insofern mit mit
Vorsicht da eben muss da getreten werden
jetzt haben wir über die militärische
Lage gesprochen jetzt ist der Beitrag
von Christian Volk auch mit Ton da über
die militärische Lage dann wollen wir
uns die Situation doch auch im Film noch
schnell angucken
ukrainische Soldaten angeblich im
Kleinen dorfried-dub in der Region
Donetzk die Ortschaft offenbar
zurückerobert die Gegenoffensive läuft
weiter das sollen diese Bilder zeigen
der Donbass hat für uns oberste
Priorität denn er ist immer noch Ziel
Nummer eins für Russland
Geländegewinne gibt es nach ukrainischen
Angaben vor allem östlich des Flusses
aus Kiel die Verteidigungslinie der
Russen durchbrochen mehrere wichtige
Verkehrsknotenpunkte wie die Stadt
cupiansk offenbar befreit doch selbst
dort gibt es noch immer heftige Gefechte
viele wollen raus aus der Kampfzone
wir kommen von der anderen Seite des
Flusses unsere ukrainischen Soldaten
kämpfen dort es wird so viel geschossen
in der gesamten Stadt cobiansk zeigt
sich die Zerstörung die Grausamkeit des
Krieges Einwohner sprechen von Folter
während der russischen Besatzung und die
Ukraine bereiten sich auf die nächsten
Gefechte vor
ja also soweit die Lage das ist eben wie
wir eben gesagt haben das Schlachtfeld
auf das Putin 300.000 neuer Rekruten
werfen will
das Entscheidende ist diese 300.000 wenn
er von der Thai Mobilmachung spricht es
geht ja nicht nur darum Männer in
Russland zu rekrutieren sondern eben
auch in den von Russland besetzten
Gebieten zu rekrutieren wir reden gleich
darüber schauen uns aber mal anhören
einfach mal was eben der Gouverneur HD
dazu sagt der ja sozusagen fern ist von
seiner Heimat weil eben die meisten
Teile von Johannes von Russen besetzt
sind der aber natürlich hört wie es denn
da mit der Rekrutierung aussieht die ja
letzten Endes dann dazu führt dass
ukrainische Männer gezwungen werden auf
Ukrainer zu schießen das ist das was
hadey uns erzählt hat
Problem ist akut denn in einem halben
Jahr wurden fast alle Männer eingezogen
die Musterung wurde aufgehoben es werden
kranke und behinderte eingezogen
es werden selbst Männer eingezogen die
von Unternehmen gesperrt sind aus
kritischer Infrastruktur
was haben Sie zu befürchten dass sie an
der Front getötet werden denn die Russen
schmeißen diese neu einberufenen
Ukrainer unmittelbar in die Hölle des
Kriegs
ja in die Hölle des Kriegs wir haben es
schon gesagt und sozusagen das Blut
vergießen geht eben auch dann damit
weiter vor Franke wir haben jetzt
gesehen es also hat beschrieben wie
fürchterlich das ist wenn eben diese
Männer rekrutiert werden aufeinander
schießen müssen dass der Krieg ja damit
eben weitergeht und weitergeht sie haben
selber schon gesagt gerade orakelnd ein
Waffenstillstand ist so schnell nicht zu
sehen ein bisschen Hoffnung des Westens
wurde ja auch darauf gesetzt dass jetzt
Proteste eben in Russland aufkommen wir
haben über die ersten Proteste berichtet
Frage könnte das größer werden könnte
sich die Hoffnung des Westens irgendwie
erfüllen dass diese Proteste dann am
Ende Putin so gefährlich werden dass es
dann eben zu einem Ende des Kriegs kommt
ich
glaube das ist
unwahrscheinlich
soweit ich in der Lage bin dass jetzt
von außen zu sehen aber auch ihr
Reporter in Moskau hat ja
treffenderweise gesagt solche
Protestbewegungen brauchen auch
Anführungen Führungspersönlichkeiten und
die sehen wir aktuell noch nicht in
Russland es ist sicherlich richtig dass
diese Mobilisierung jetzt den Krieg nach
Russland gebracht hat also in den Alltag
der Menschen bis hier die letzten 7
Monate war ja immer die narrative
spezialoperation und das machen eben
unsere Truppen da und das hat die
Menschen in Russland letztendlich wenig
tangiert das hat sich jetzt geändert
also sowohl in den großen Städten als
auch eben vor allen Dingen in den
Inventar Republiken wird rekrutiert wird
eingezogen auch eben wie wir gehört
haben Männer die überhaupt nicht wollen
dass das hat einen Einfluss und deswegen
regt sich Widerstand das mögen wir
begrüßen aber von allem was wir aktuell
aus dem russischen Regime hören
erscheint es nie jetzt erstmal
unwahrscheinlich dass daraus eine große
Revolution entwickelt letztendlich kann
man das natürlich nie sagen und es hängt
doch davon ab wie Mobilisierung
weiterläuft wie der Krieg weiter läuft
aber sagen wir mal so ich würde da jetzt
nicht die großen Hoffnungen draufsetzen
im Westen dass sich das russische Regime
das russische regieren quasi von von
innen implodiert und sich dieser Krieg
damit regelt das erscheint mir erstmal
unwahrscheinlich
dann haben wir zum Schluss auch noch
eine Frage hier über youtube ist sie
gekommen von Chris on air hallo besteht
aktuell die Gefahr das ist noch mal eine
Entscheidungsschlacht geben wird so wie
es sie Anfang des Jahres in Kiew um Kiew
herumgegeben hat sie haben schon gesagt
die Dinge sind schwer vorherzusehen
viele Satz ich in diesem Krieg auch
anders entwickelt als vorhergesehen aber
wir erinnern uns eben da hat sozusagen
Russland alles in die Waagschale
geworfen ist gescheitert man kann sagen
die große Schlacht um Kiew eben verloren
ist es möglich dass es irgendwie eine
derartige große Schlachtern eben im
Osten oder Südosten eben geben wird
also das ist noch mal zu einer
Entscheidungsschlacht kommt das ist
absolut möglich ich würde allerdings
aktuell vielleicht eher in die andere
Richtung gehen das ist eine
Entscheidungsschlacht sein könnte dass
eben die Ukrainer vielleicht eine ihrer
wichtigen Städte zurückerobern können
die Frage ist wie viel kann Russland
tatsächlich noch in die Waagschale
werfen und von dem was wir jetzt sehen
und kann leider immer nur sagen so genau
können wir es nicht wissen und da ist
viel Unsicherheit drin aber von dem was
wir sehen erscheint es mir sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass das Russland es
schafft sich jetzt in der in der
Hinterhand so zu organisieren und so zu
mobilisieren dass man da wirklich noch
mal signifikant drucken und zwar eben
gut ausgebildete Truppen und Material
etc aufbringen kann um noch mal ein ein
Großangriff auf also auch hier von mir
sowieso nicht aber auch andere Städte zu
fahren leider immer mit der mit der
Klammer es ist schwierig woher zu sagen
aber ich erwarte das jetzt eigentlich
eher nicht meines Erachtens gerade die
Situation dass beide Seiten also Ukraine
versuchen zurück zu erobern aber aber
vor allen Dingen russland versucht sich
jetzt auch in der Position zu bringen
die sich gut verteidigen lässt gerade
vor dem Winter denn im Winter ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich dass ich das ganze noch
mal etwas verlangsamt und ja das eben
russland versucht Gebiete zu halten die
ist jetzt hat solange es kann um da ja
wie jetzt gesehen haben und wie auch
ihre Sendung angefangen hat eben Fakten
zu schaffen Fakten zu schaffen mit
solchen Referenten diese Gebiete zu
besetzen sie als Russisch zu bezeichnen
an zu annektieren und somit auch auch
die Rückeroberung noch mal noch mal
schwieriger zu machen
und Frau Franke das führt genau zur
letzten Frage die man einfach heute an
dem heutigen Tag stellen muss sie sagen
Fakten schaffen es geht um das Ziel das
haben wir deutlich gemacht dass eben die
russisch besetzten Gebiete der Ukraine
einfach völkerrechtswig eben annektiert
werden aber das Russland dann eben sagen
kann das ist Russland wenn die Ukraine
versuchen diese Gebiete zurück zu
erobern dann wird Russland angegriffen
das haben wir deutlich gemacht und heute
hat der Ex-Präsident mit WDF der eben
stellvertretender Vorsitzender des
russischen Sicherheitsrates ist noch
einmal heute ganz frisch gesagt russland
hat das Recht wenn nötig Atomwaffen
einzusetzen das ist schon mal gesagt
worden aber heute hat er das noch mal
wiederholt und auf die Frage ob das denn
auch die Position des Kremls ist hat er
dann eben auf hat der Kremmen Sprecher
peschkov auf die militärische Doktrin
Russlands verwiesen das ist immer die
Möglichkeit eines nuklearen gegenschlags
oder nuklearer Schläge vorsieht wenn
eben russisches nicht angegriffen wird
müssen wir denn jetzt ernsthaft damit
rechnen dass in diesem Krieg wenn die
Ukraine weiter versuchen ihr Gebiet
zurück zu erobern das Russland dann eben
taktische Atomwaffen einsetzt
es ist natürlich wahnsinnig zynisch also
Russland droht ja schon länger eben mit
mit dem Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen in
diesen Krieg die gute Nachricht in
Anführungsstrichen ist dass wir nicht
sehen dass Russland seine nukleark
Kräfte in Position bringt dass die
mobilisiert werden also da hat sich
außerhalb der Rhetorik nichts getan zum
Glück aber diese Position zu sagen wir
greifen fremde Staatsgebiet
Staatsgebiete Ukraine an besetzen das
eine Tieren das deklarieren das als
Russland und wenn man dann versucht ist
zurück zu erobern dann sagen wir das ist
ein Angriff auf Russland und wir haben
das Recht Atombomben zu zünden oder
nuklear zurückzuschlagen das ist
natürlich
wahnsinnig zynische Politik und dem dem
dürfen wir überhaupt nicht
recht geben dass das dürfen wir so nicht
akzeptieren das ist völkerrechtswidrig
das ist absolut inakzeptabel die
nukleare Gefahr natürlich muss man sie
immer mitdenken weil wir es mit einer
nuklearen Macht zu tun haben es ist aber
auch nicht so dass uns das komplett in
Starre verfallen lassen sollte auf die
Ukraine nicht wird auch die Ukraine
nicht es ist auch militärisch wenig
sinnvoll für Russland Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen man muss mal die Frage
stellen was wollten Sie denn angreifen
was ist hier die Überlegung also das ist
militärisch nicht wahnsinnig sinnvoll
aber natürlich die Rhetorik ist da die
muss mitgedacht werden Russland spielt
da ganz klar mit das macht das Ganze so
so schwierig und so unangenehm aber wir
dürfen dieser narrative nicht nachgeben
das ist jetzt plötzlich dass diese
ukrainischen Gebiete jetzt russisches
Studium sind und das Russland jetzt
irgendein Recht auf diese Gebiete hat
und irgendein recht sie dann wie auch
immer nuklearde anderweitig zu
verteidigen
dann danken wir ganz ganz ganz herzlich
für diese einschränkt Schätzungen auch
die klaren Aussagen Ulrike Franke sagen
vielen vielen Dank nach London und
vielleicht bis demnächst dann wieder wir
beobachten die Lage und die Entwicklung
weiter vielen Dank dass Sie mit dabei
waren tschüss ja das war unser ZDF heute
livestream am letzten Tag der
sogenannten Referenden pseudo-referenten
die in den in einigen russisch besetzten
Gebieten in der Ukraine abgehalten
worden sind interessante Gespräche die
doch immer wieder dazu führen man muss
weiter schauen die Kristallkugel haben
wir nicht aber doch viele Informationen
die wir heute gesammelt haben ich sage
großes Dankeschön einen schönen Abend
noch und vielen Dank für das Interesse